meantime the Clark County School
District is preparing for summer school
but they're also trying to figure out
how to bring back students to campus
this fall now the superintendent
addressed a lot of questions earlier
this afternoon and Kristian Drummond has
the latest on what both teachers and
students can expect dr. Jarrah is
putting together a working group right
now it will consist of parents teachers
central staff administrators and others
in the district
their goal figure out what the first day
of school will look like on August 10th
there will be a stagger whether it'll be
a face-to-face obviously you know too
early to tell but we're gonna have plans
in place so our first meeting will be
you know the first 14 days of May the
type of school schedule remains unknown
but dr. Jarrah says clean facilities
remain a priority for the district when
staff and students return he also
mentioned the district is looking at
kovat 19 and antibody testing there are
no policies yet about anyone needing
testing in order to go back to school
we're gonna rely on the other medical
experts if they're going to require you
know right now we just have to be ready
regarding summer school the district
will offer credit recovery for students
between 6th and 12th grades via distance
education CCSD is also connecting with
community partners like the YMCA to help
students keep up with their academics
and sharing some of our curriculum
content so it's not just you know play
so there's an opportunity for them as
well to to try to catch up in some of
the learning loss that we're we're
projected to see and experience this
summer as for district budget reductions
dr. jar says any announcement from the
state has now been delayed it will
likely not be known this week as
previously expected reporting outside
the Clark County school district
administration building Kristen Drummond
8 News now